la tempête Fiona a durement frappé l'est
du pays laissant derrière elle des
dégâts bien visibles des stations
services détruites des poteaux
électriques des routes bloquées mais des
habitants qui gardent le moral comme
Georges McDonald's qui a reçu la visite
du Premier ministre de la nouvelle école
sont tombés sur sa maison et par miracle
elle est toujours debout l'électricité
manque tout comme chez plusieurs autres
résidents qui font la queue pour se
ravitailler en essence pour leur
génératrice
à Chanel Port aux Basques les dégâts
sont frappants des maisons éventries et
des débris éparpillées dans la
communauté la municipalité a déclaré
l'état d'urgence et décrété des
évacuations ces personnes ont tout perdu
et de quoi demain sera fait reste un
inconnu
aux Îles de la Madeleine il ne reste que
des débris du chalet familial d'Isabelle
Cormier vieux de 40 ans l'an dernier
elle craignait déjà que les tempêtes
répétitives ne l'emportent ce qu'on est
complètement exposé chaque année on se
dit c'est la dernière c'est la dernière
mais finalement on a de la chance une
chance qui a malheureusement mal tourné
cette année avec Fiona dans ce camping
du sud-est du Nouveau-Brunswick les
propriétaires de roulottes tentent de
sauver les meubles pendant que d'autres
tirent un traits sur la leur
est finie parce que faudrait tout
déchirer l'intérieur
enlevez l'isolation qui a dedans puis je
pense pas que ça vaut la peine au cours
des prochaines semaines nous travaillons
en collaboration avec nos homologues
provinciaux pour les aider à retrouver
ensemble de normalité le plus rapidement
possible
dévastatrice et c'est solidairement que
les plus touchés comptent se relever de
cet événement sans précédent
merci Daniel Kadjo Radio-Canada Montréal